sept moines français enlevé il y a deux
mois ont été exécutés et probablement
égorgé
l annonce de la mort des moines le 21
mai 1996
aucun doute ils ont été victimes du
terrorisme comme une dizaine d'autres
religieux le jour même le gia le groupe
islamiste armé revendique ces exécutions
le texte daté du 21 mai portant le
numéro 44 et de cachets habituel du gia
est signée par le chef présumé du groupe
islamique armé
jamais le site uni il accuse le
président français le ministre des
affaires étrangères d'avoir déclaré je
cite ne pas vouloir négocier avec le gia
mais cette version officielle sera
troublé à plusieurs reprises une
première fois en 2001 dans un livre
l'auteur rené guitton affirme que la
france aurait pu faire aboutir les
négociations à une libération des moines
ce que dément le premier ministre de
l'époque si j'avais eu connaissance au
moment des faits de propositions
crédibles susceptibles de sauver la vie
des moines je les aurai naturellement
prise en considération en 2002 côté
algérien cette fois le général
abdelkader teague a fait des révélations
étonnantes
les religieux j'ai vu selon lui ce ne
sont pas les islamistes du gia les
responsables mais l'armée algérienne
alors que le pays lutte contre le
terrorisme les autorités aurait
manigancé ces exécutions dans un seul
but poussé la france à soutenir
l'algérie sans réserve dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
en 2009 la sphère prend une autre
tournure celle de la bavure militaire le
général bugeaud valter en poste à
l'ambassade de france à alger à l'époque
raconte les confidences d'un proche d'un
pilote d'hélicoptère de l'armée
algérienne c'était donc une zone vide et
les hélicoptères ont vu un bivouac
comme cette zone était vidée ça ne
pouvait être qu'un groupe armé
ils ont donc tiré sur le bivouac et se
sont ensuite posés une fois posés ils
ont découvert qu'ils avaient tiré
notamment sur les moines
les corps des moines étaient criblés de
balles
voilà qui expliquerait la décapitation
et des corps jamais retrouvé
pour en avoir le coeur net les juges
demandent à exhumer les têtes enterré au
monastère de tibhirine
ce qui ne sera fait qu'en 2014 et il
faut attendre 2016 pour les résultats
des autopsies
pourquoi refuser obstinément depuis un
an et demi de donner à la justice
française de ces prélèvements
si ce n'est qu'on a quelque chose à
cacher les éléments en finit par arriver
en juin 2016 vingt ans après les faits
ce qu'il révèle c'est une date de mort
antérieure à celle annoncée au moins
trois semaines plus tôt de quoi faire
vaciller rend peu plus la version
officielle
[Musique]